tropical storm elsa now churning  northward on a projected path that will  take it over some of the nation's  biggest  cities while most of florida dodged a  bullet with elsa the state's northern  gulf coast wasn't so lucky the storm  made landfall there packing wind gusts  up to 65 miles per hour flooding roads  down in trees and leaving thousands  without power  several suspected tornadoes were  reported as elsa lingered  over the south the sky over here got  real dark  and then it real bright over here and  then all of a sudden the rain stopped  just dead stop so i walked out on my  porch and i look over  and i could actually see the twister  going by  this is dangerous this is force mother  nature is that you know  taking effect the storm is now creeping  up the east coast the national weather  service says elsa could intensify  as it spins towards the atlantic